at first glance the war in Ukraine might
look like something from the 20th
century
you see a sort of trench-like landscape
that would be familiar to soldiers from
1915.
but it holds many lessons for conflicts
to come
while boots on the ground still matter
Russia has moved to tighten its
conscription law pressing more men to
fight
new tech is making a huge difference
there's this idea of revolutions and
Military Affairs and they're typically
attributed to technology
drone will definitely be very important
in any conflict between Taiwan and China
as the world enters a new era of
increased conflicts
what does the future of combat look like
this may be the moment where War really
does become something else
[Music]
foreign
runs air logics
a company that makes drones for the
Ukrainian military
today he's testing their Flagship
product a reconnaissance drone called
the gore
as well as a smaller loiter in munition
or Kamikaze drone
over 20 such systems have already been
sent to the front line
it's a successful culmination of months
of research and development
weather drones are adapted to be used as
Weapons or as guides
both Russia and Ukraine are sending huge
numbers onto the battlefield
we're now estimating that the Ukrainian
armed forces are losing some 10 000
drones a month so just the extent to
which drones are being used is
definitely noteworthy
drones have flown in walls before but
what's different in Ukraine is how
they're being used
what I think it's teaching us is that
just because drones are being shot down
doesn't mean they aren't absolutely
indispensable if the Drone is shot down
no problem it's done its job these are
almost becoming like consumables on the
battlefield
is
effective
uh
Search and Destroy drone missions are a
huge part of the new tech dominating the
battlefield
but its artillery batteries flying
drones to show them where to aim their
guns that are using them with the most
effect
without expandable drones as their eyes
and ears Shooters would be nearly blind
just how many drones are being used is
an invaluable lesson for any future
conflict
quantity can really matter in a war and
quantity as a quality of its own that's
something that in the west we may have
forgotten to some extent we have
relatively shallow arsenals with regard
to ammunition and and things like that
and now we're realizing that yeah in in
these kind of rather large conventional
Wars you also just need a lot of drones
and a lot of everything really whether
they're consumable or large and long
range Ukraine has demonstrated drones
will be regular players in wars of the
future
but the intelligence drones collect is
only useful if there's a means of
communicating it to the wider Force
and in the battlefield that isn't always
easy
soldiers like favorski are at the
Forefront of that challenge
they risk their live training soldiers
how to use technology that has become a
Lifeline for Ukraine
starlink
huh
away from the battlefield maintaining
the equipment is essential
s
darling is a satellite constellation
owned by SpaceX an American rocket
company
hit up with more than 4 000 low orbit
satellites that provide off-grid
internet access
a Lifeline when Heavy Artillery is
constantly battering your ground-based
utilities
and crucially it's allowing soldiers on
the ground to share images from drone
feeds to connect targets with the
nearest artillery team a kind of uber
for howitzers
foreign
other countries are taking note
Chinese generals have been watching
American war since 1991 when America's
lightning-fast victory over Iraq woke
them up to the power of American
intelligence and digital networks and
from that moment on the people's
Liberation Army of China realized not
only that they had to be able to wage a
similar kind of warfare but that if they
were going to be able to defeat America
and its allies in Asia they would have
to take out not just weapons and
Soldiers on the ground but you take out
the systems that they rely on
Taiwan constantly in China's crosses
knows its undersea internet cables could
be cut in the event of an invasion
it too sees the value of a starlink type
constellation and a future conflict
satellite Communications in the future
are going to be that absolutely critical
element that allows census to be
connected to Shooters in a timely
fashion in a way that ensures if a
soldier sees a tank and sends that
information back you can hit it in a
time scale that is minutes not hours by
which the tank may be miles away
installing may help information move
quicker and more securely
but in wars of the future artificial
intelligence will help to make sense of
that information
hello I'm Tom standage Deputy editor at
The Economist if you're enjoying this
film why not take out a subscription to
The Economist you'll receive daily and
weekly analysis of global Affairs and
you can read us online in the app and
listen to our audio Edition for the best
offer click on the link
thank you Generals in Ukraine are
already adapting AI technology to help
them plan what to attack what resources
to use and when
a kind of Google Maps for armies
it's another glimpse of how new tech
will be helping tomorrow's soldiers
you'll use these virtual simulations for
various training or experimental
purposes
Jennifer McArdle should know she
specializes in training soldiers for
future Wars Ukraine has been a great
example of how the ubiquity and
proliferation of sensors has allowed
them to more effectively close kill
chains
shortening a kill chain means speeding
up the time between finding a Target and
destroying it
it's a maritime Patrol aircraft can you
show me their position
satellites radar and drones provide an
overwhelming amount of data from the
battlefield
and sorting through it is hugely time
intensive
if you're able to use AI to go through
that information and to be able to
present information that matters for a
decision maker you have speed you can
work through that decision-making cycle
much more quickly than you can right now
and AI isn't just helping to make
decisions
it's also guiding the machines
Shield AI is a military tech company
working to build an AI pilot
artificial intelligence software that
can fly unmanned craft during combat
the future of warfare is going to be
characterized by thousands of unmanned
aerial Vehicles unmanned surface
Vehicles unmanned underwater vehicles
and what is going to be the
differentiating factor among all these
vehicles is the level of intelligence
the level of autonomy integrated into
each one of those Vehicles you'll see
unmanned systems outnumber the number of
War fighters on the front lines of these
conflicts they will play a key role in
any Battle of the
business is booming for military
startups
since 2021 the American defense
department spanning on AI allocated by
Financial year has more than doubled
and NATO is also heavily investing
there has been a wave of venture capital
that has gone to defense technology
companies I think it's because you see
an industry that is fundamentally
transforming the products and
capabilities that are going to matter in
the next conflict are going to be
derived from software capabilities from
AI
but there are concerns about leaving the
decision to kill to an algorithm
there's this worry I think in popular
culture that AI is going to spawn these
Terminators and while I think there is
reason to be cautious I do think it's
important we don't engage in hyperbole
in the US and in a lot of Western
countries we have made the deliberate
decision that when it comes to decisions
around lethality a human will always be
in or on that decision-making Loop
where this I think does become a little
bit worrisome is that other countries
haven't made that same normative
decision
over a hundred countries have military
systems with some degree of autonomy
[Music]
it's easy to see how a weapon that
thinks for itself could be an advantage
if you are a commander and you launch
the weapon let's say an aircraft and its
Communications are jammed if it spots a
Target on the ground are you going to
wait for your communication link to be
restored by which time the target may
have gone away or are you going to give
the weapon the authority to take the
shot itself
from a purely military perspective that
Independence is hugely valuable under
those kinds of uh comms denied
environment
but for now humans largely maintain
lethal control
I'm skeptical that AI on its own can
turn the tide of War I think we have to
be very cognizant of the fact AI remains
incredibly brittle it struggles to adapt
to unexpected situations and scenarios
and warfare is just full of the
unexpected it's replete with fog and
friction
and in wars of the future like now not
all fighting will be done with bullets
and missiles
over 8 000 kilometers from Ukraine in
the South China Sea
there may be fewer trenches but a
furious struggle is still underway
China has long claimed sovereignty over
Taiwan a democratic self-governing
Island that it sees as a breakaway
province but geography is on taiwan's
side we're trying not to launch a
straightforward invasion of Taiwan there
are many difficulties including
launching the largest ever amphibious
operations since
um Normandy this will be extremely
difficult for China The Landing itself
is also extremely difficult because
China hasn't actually conducted any
kinetic military operations since 1979.
so this was a big gamble
in the face of such challenges China may
try a different attack if it invades
Taiwan
[Music]
the principal celebration Army believes
in the three Warfare Doctrine which
requires communication with your
potential audience in order to achieve a
psychological effect
cyber provides a very powerful means for
them to extend their concept such as
propaganda such as United Fund
operations if they could do that then
this is relatively cheap you could
conduct an entire Year's worth of
operations and the cost would not nearly
be as much as one ballistic missile and
cyber warfare isn't just a psychological
weapon
they could cut off power supplies
critical military infrastructures such
as surveillance radar stations and keep
Taiwan blind death to facilitate further
kinetic operations
it may sound like a cleaner version of
future War but when it comes to conflict
there's no escape from attrition
his partner are preparing for him to
return to the front
is
[Music]
another versions
of
it's very easy to get caught up in the
hardware of this conflict the drones the
tanks the satellites but it is very
important to understand ultimately this
is still people
mostly men often very young men holding
guns firing at the enemy and suffering
trauma life-changing injuries and death
even in a war with high levels of
technological sophistication in the end
we still need to be prepared for the 18
year old dying somewhere in the mud the
fundamental nature of War as a human
conflict with humans killing each other
I don't think that that is going to go
away
war is still ultimately irreducibly
about that Clash of arms waged often at
Close Quarters in which bodies pile up
the societies are ravaged and each
country's youth the most talented Affair
Young Generation are lost in huge
numbers
thank you for watching so read more of
our coverage on the future of warfare
please click on the link and don't
forget to subscribe
foreign
[Music]